thank you
hey you are you wasting your time on
social media again your brothers and
sisters in the slam net from Norway are
establishing a Masjid a dawa Center
establishing a Masjid to convey The
Message of Islam is one of the best
Deeds a Muslim can do there's a huge
need for it in Norway you know this and
I know this so that makes the Lord even
greater so give generously and Allah
azzawajal give you even
so we're just going around and asking
people here we're doing a social
experiment okay or testing the knowledge
of the Norwegian people as it relates to
Islam as a religion okay if I was to ask
you about um Islam what would you say
the first thing brings to mind when I
say the religion of Islam Allah
okay yeah interesting and what what do
you understand from the religion itself
the practice or also ask you to expound
a little bit more
I would say uh
mostly related to men and the women and
that's not the same rights and yes
something else
[Music]
very um
uh they talk a lot about the older men
are more power when they're younger and
and it's a huge solution so if that was
the case you should be quite a happy man
you should be
I'm only kidding I'm only kidding you're
a very young man of course yeah in
spirit and in appearance but I was going
to say look I mean these are the kinds
of things we're trying to in a sense not
challenge but trying to discuss at least
because it's true to say that Islam has
a different world view yeah than say for
example Western Enlightenment thinking I
mean some people go to two different
extremes on this issue some deny that
there's any difference at all which is
unintelligible and not true and some
some say that actually the the
differences are so much that there
cannot be any cooperation
and I think what we're trying to do is
we're trying to establish a middle
ground here what do you think of that
approach
I would say I think most people would be
much happier if they uh
believed in other people and not so much
in what's
in God or Allah or anything I think I
think more I'll believe more in people
than in any religion yes okay but then
the question is this is that you know
when we talk about belief in in a
general sense right you said it first we
said what is Islam who said God or Allah
right you believe in god oh I'm not sure
do you believe in God or do you no yeah
I mean most most Scandinavian people now
I think it's one of the most Atheist
Societies or at least agnostic
irreligious Societies in the world why
you're an individual who has seen maybe
I'm guessing you're at least 50 years
old
conservative involved that that is a
surprise I was going to say that most
people you've seen maybe a shift between
a more religious Scandinavia and the
less religious one what do you think the
turning points were
because what I said that the priests and
the the the
leaders
view of the homosexual and women that is
what makes that's makes the difference
because so yeah if they don't accept
homophili homophil people yeah other
women then I don't respect them oh yeah
I see what you're saying even if this
man converts now which let's say I could
get him to convert but it doesn't mean
anything if there's not an Aftercare
program if there's not someone to speak
to them if there's not someone to to
help them and we need to help them by
clicking the link below right now
because this is the biggest outreach
program in Scandinavia
so click the link below and we'll be
able to do this project where we can do
this download to the people in the
streets of Norway and in Sweden and in
Denmark and in all of Scandinavia today
click the link below you cannot afford
to miss out on the submissions
[Music]
so in a sense it seems like your biggest
qualm against religion in general is
gender equality and lgbtq rights okay
can I challenge this a little bit in a
sentence say let's say for the sake of
argument let's assume that the abrahamic
religions like Islam Christianity
Judaism all three of them
you can interpret them in their most
traditional form as separating the
rights between men and women in some
cases yeah yeah and also suggesting that
homosexuality is a sin okay okay let's
just assume that those two things are
true okay if I were to say what's the
evidence against those two Notions what
would you say as someone who's like a
western Enlightenment person some people
are women and some people are home of
Faith homosexual yeah that's that's uh
that's that's uh against that's what I
can you can say that one peop one person
are less worthy than the other and
that's why if once people say I'm
homosexual then he's just as worthy and
as anyone who says he's not I understand
absolutely I mean I can see what you're
coming from in terms of human worth and
these person's a human this person's a
human and so on but what we're saying
here is something a little bit different
which is that if I were to ask you this
question why is homosexuality like okay
morality for example like in other words
where'd you get your right and wrong
from would you where'd you understand
what's right and where what's wrong
because they exists if with one person
have no legs yes
and then another person no arms and one
people are homosexual and the one is a
uh dumb or death it's just it's just uh
it's just another type of human it's not
a diff it's not nothing should say that
that's more right or wrong no I accept
in terms of how people are this person
is not better than that person on basis
on that that person has certain feelings
of the opposite gender that the other
one doesn't have oh that person has legs
or that person doesn't have legs that
person's a man that person's own to be
fair just to steal man the opposition I
think all three religions could argue
that that's the case we would agree like
for example Christians Muslims and Jews
all of them would say that okay we're
not saying that there's anything wrong
with a person just because they have
those things but what they're saying is
that these actions for example these
beliefs are problematic now my question
is where did you get your beliefs that's
this is right and this is wrong how do
you ascertain what's right and what's
wrong because
um
I mean it's just then uh I mean
it's just accept you have to accept
whatever it is and what what I feel is
that the most religion like Muslims and
Christianity and Jews they all are made
by men who think they want power over
other and they if they say Allah said
told me then they said okay then Allah
told me then you have to do what I do
because I say because I I help my my
words from Allah and who can say that
nobody what was your name again my
friend tall tall yeah tall tall like
yeah so I believe in the northern yeah
okay so I was going to say this is that
now everyone gets there right and wrong
from somewhere okay now you've said that
religion the people that get religion
unless for the sake of arguments say
Okay most of the religions have
protagonists which are male and the
Assumption from a secular mind of course
is that these males themselves created
the religion and therefore they're doing
it for self-interest okay so I
understand the argument I'm saying that
even notwithstanding that argument
for example you saw in the 21st century
in 2023 you've gotten your right and
wrong from somewhere right so if you
were if you were born 400 years ago
you're right and wrong would have been
different maybe right that's right
believable yeah and because the society
that you would have lived in for example
when they were worshiping Thor in the
Nordic regions right for example it
would have been a different one so they
might have believed in the very same
things as Christians and Jews and
Muslims believe in now right 400 years
ago maybe even 100 years ago frankly
maybe your grandfather or even your
father might have had those beliefs now
what I'm saying is how do you know that
those beliefs those set of beliefs are
true
today in 2023 nobody can tell okay
the only thing this matter is here now
and I can't I can't prove anything
what's happened before and I can't
really it's like this is how I think it
is I get it so I think that what we need
to remember here because I think when it
comes to religion right in general
people have kind of like a discourse
which is that we are the secularists for
example or we are the neutral in the
party we have we assume neutrality and
the religious is not neutral right but
what I'm saying is what I'm trying to
propose you is actually their secularism
is not a neutral proposition
liberalism is not a neutral proposition
pro-lgbt is not a new proposition the
idea that men and women are not just
identical or just to say they're equal
in roles for example is something which
is not a neutral proposition these are
all propositions which require evidence
themselves which is why I'm saying that
when I brought back to your life you're
like you know in your 50 Years of Living
whatever it is that you must have seen
the change at what point in your life
did you decide actually this was where
I'm going to take my right and wrong
from and this is what yeah this is what
I'm telling you I don't know what's
right I'm just I and I mean the more you
know this less less you know in a way
where the life goes on I know I was sure
when I was 15 then I know because yeah I
think everything is
and I'm happy with that I think it's
okay it's I think okay not to know and I
I think that's it was the wrong way with
all the relation that they think they
know the truth and that's enough
I understand
do you ever consider death
yeah and when you consider death what do
you what do you think about that how do
you make sense of that I think that is
uh it's a very good question because
then I think I think it's then it's over
like like you know when something burns
up it's it's finished I think that's
life is when you live and when you not
live you're dead I think it's it's like
I understand what you're saying but
could you entertain the possibility that
there'll be a continuation of life after
death
I I don't need it I don't I don't need I
I of course this could be but who knows
nobody will know and I don't need to
know either because Justice I think it's
exciting to live and I don't
I don't really
think too much about what's up it
happens when it happens do you not know
or do you not want to know I I do not
know you do not but you want to know
if I had an envelope in my pocket right
which said to you I have the definitive
answer of what happens after death would
you want to open that no
I don't think I would like to on that
bombshell my friend thank you so much
for your interview it's been a pleasure
talking to you my friend thank you so
much take care yeah
right what we saw there interestingly
was the mindset of an individual who
doesn't want to know doesn't want to
understand but at least engaged with the
issues and it's not that you want to
convert everybody in Norway that's not
the aim or objective the aim objective
just to Simply get people to think spark
some kind of thought process in their
mind Pew research has actually done a
research on the most racist countries in
the world and the least racist countries
in the world and they found that the
most racist countries in Europe for
example are those who have the least
interaction with say for example people
of different races and likewise someone
can say the same thing about people of
different religions as well and so just
having these conversations already
fulfills an objective of humanizing
Muslim people and encouraging
normalizing discussions about Religion
and Ethics and putting us on somewhat of
an even playing field in those
discussions so if it's not conversion
it's also at least going to be
normalization and so the Scandinavian
initiative here where the tower Outreach
projects which is attempting to
normalize relationships between Muslim
people and other people normalize Islam
in this country doing dawa and bringing
people to Islam strengthening the Muslim
Community is the biggest of this kind
and so you do really want to miss an
opportunity like this where you can
encourage these kinds of discussions
this kind of Outreach I don't think you
do and these are the efforts that were
slam that has put forward of course in
creating this Masjid end dollar Center
we can have an Outreach project which
will fulfill those two objectives in a
way that's never been fulfilled before
in Scandinavian history and that's why I
say click on the button below and donate
right now brothers and sisters let me
introduce you to Norway this is a
European country where the vast majority
of people have become irreligious there
are 200 000 Muslims of a population of
about 5 million and most of these 200
000 Muslims have no idea how to explain
Islam to their non-muslim friends and
neighbors what that means to change
Allah sent his Messenger to call people
to eternal success and that is why
Muslims in Norway are now establishing a
Masjid and Tower Center to enhance the
Norwegian dower but they cannot do this
alone we need to support them if you
donate to the schools you will insha
Allah reap the rewards of thousands of
Muslims coming back to Islam and many of
those will become Dwight and invite to
Islam you will share in the reward for
all those shihadas and Good Deeds to
come inshallah so click the link and
donate now and share the video for extra
reward